welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in heavyweight tom aspinall took to
instagram to thank his fans team and
medical specialists after his horrific
knee injury at ufc london the freak
accident ended what was sure to be an
electric bout with fellow heavyweight
contender curtis blades in the post
sunday night aspinal said
last night wasn't my night my training
camp in the build-up to the fight has
been brilliant sometimes these things
happen now is the time to recover
rebuild and come back stronger wanted to
say thank you to the ufc the doctors and
paramedics that looked after me but also
to the fans for all the messages you've
sent and support you've given me in the
build up to the fight and after the
freak injury you're all amazing want to
thank curtis for being a true gentleman
it didn't work out how we both wanted
but to come and see me after for a beer
makes you a legend in my eyes finally my
team and my family we all know this is
elite sport we live to fight another day
big love tom despite being disappointed
he couldn't prove himself against an
elite competitor curtis blades doesn't
plan to wait for tom's return to run it
back at the post fight press conference
in a video obtained by mma junkie blades
indicated he is only thinking about
moving forward i have no idea what
happened
he landed the kick
i i went to counter he dropped
that's all i know
i'm not risking my ranking i won i won
the fight
heading into this fight i envisioned the
winner
which is me the winner of this fight
would be fighting the winner of huivas
and gone so i'm not going to pass up an
opportunity to fight those guys when
it's right there to wait for a small to
heal and run it back
after his second round submission of
jordan levitt patty pimblett made the
most of his opportunity with the mic to
advocate for men's mental health
listen
if you're a man
and you've got weight on your shoulders
and you think the only way you can solve
this by killing yourself
please speak to
someone speak to anyone
[Applause]
the move which was universally praised
wasn't enough to change the opinion of
muhammad
in his post fight press conference
mahaya have told reporters he doesn't
believe that pimlic is a good role model
there's so many guys that don't get a
lot of media attention that should get
it example arnold allen it's leon
edwards it's tom aspinall nathaniel wood
these guys are amazing good examples i
don't disrespect media guys but you give
a [ __ ] guy like patty pindlet
attention these guys never ever reach
the top 15 like realistically who
understands mma they'll never reach i
don't think he's a great role model for
young guys please follow tom aspinall
arnold allen leon edwards real men
outside the cage and inside the cage i'm
proud to be on the same card as a man
like tom aspinall
mojave continued by blasting pinlet for
mooning reporters at the official
weigh-ins for ufc london this guy pulls
his pants down a man doesn't do this
woman don't do this stuff pull his pants
down get fat drink beer like animal men
in liverpool i know real scouse people
they don't do stuff like this this guy
is just too much i'm not a hater i just
want to see a younger generation follow
a real man
light heavyweight alexander rocket
shared a video with his instagram
followers after an altercation he had at
ufc london with jimmy manual according
to rocket she was sucker punched by
manual after the event
jimmy manuela you piece of [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] man what a [ __ ] move
you did last night on me
guys
i'll just let you know that after the
event at ufc london
i was escorting
the securities escorting me to the
transfer to the hotel back to the hotel
and mr still sleep was sitting
in my row at the end of the road so i
needed to pass him by
and i passed by and
he talked to me something i didn't
really pay attention first and the
second
i have nothing to do with that guy you
know for me
this is over so i started to turn away
and he sucker punched me and even in
that close range he couldn't catch my
head i think he hit me with the four uh
arm on my neck and the securities were
so fast here and they separate us man
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] move you knew that
i'm be alone in london by myself you
knew that i had surgery nine weeks ago
and you did this
man you're such a bad bad loser and i
want to people know what a piece of [ __ ]
you are you know
i'm gonna stay in your head forever i
retire you
i knocked you out
and the world saw that so
happy retirement mr sleep the pair share
a history together inside of the octagon
with rockets winning via head kick ko 42
seconds into the ballot manual shared
his side of the story with bjpen.com
it wasn't a sucker punch we were face to
face and i slapped him and he moved away
and did nothing the security came and
that was the end of it and i didn't make
a scene i told him i was going to slap
him when i saw him and that's what i did
he was walking past and i said to him
what are you saying now and he was
acting all confused he tried to keep
walking so i slapped him and he was like
a fox and headlights he didn't say
anything after manuwa continued that
it's not over the fact he lost tarakic
but that the austrian is disrespectful
as a winner
the fight is the fight it's not the
first time i've lost i've lost a rumble
johnson dustin ozdimir i've lost the
blockovic and we're all friends now i
text them every now and then to check in
and we're all respectful rakit i don't
know what it is i got asked by a fan
what fight do i want back and i said the
one with rockets because i feel like i
didn't get to show my real skills he
came back and said oh i knocked you out
do you need some money off the 50 bags i
earned or he sends stuff he bought and
says he bought it using the money he got
from knocking me out just being proper
disrespectful and i said to him when i
see you keep the same energy and that's
it i just had to give him what he
deserves for acting like a troll and a
keyboard warrior online
thick boy fight news reached out to
lightweight contender michael chandler
for his thoughts on how the ufc london
card went down the atmosphere was
electric the uk crowd is just different
the way they get behind their fighters
is amazing
molly looked sharp and dominant patty
overcame a very sticky grappling attack
showed composure and got the sub then
got the whole crowd going on the mic it
was unfortunate how aspinal and blades
ended because their first few exchanges
said the fight was about to be very fun
at heavyweight
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
you